a
el embarazo adolescente tiene profundas
consecuencias personales y sociales pero
también impacta en la economía de los
países de acuerdo con un reciente
informe del fondo de población de
naciones unidas'
el costo por año del embarazo
adolescente en argentina es de 835
millones de dólares
esa cifra surge de estimar por un lado
cuánto gasta el estado en acompañar esos
embarazos nacimientos y maternidades
tempranas y por el otro cuánto se pierde
por la limitación de estas adolescentes
de participar en el mercado de trabajo y
por un menor aporte tributario siete de
cada diez embarazos adolescentes en
argentina no son intencionales no son
buscados según datos oficiales en 2006
para ayudar a prevenir el embarazo
adolescente el país implemente una ley
de educación sexual integral enfocada en
niños niñas y adolescentes y esta semana
el poder ejecutivo presentó un proyecto
de ley para legalizar el aborto que
incluye previsiones para informar acerca
de métodos anticonceptivos y proveerlos
cuando una mujer solicite la
interrupción del embarazo
[Música]
en ecuador la falta de prevención del
embarazo en niñas y adolescentes lo
ubica entre los 6 países de
latinoamérica y el caribe con la mayor
tasa de embarazos en el mundo es que si
en el año 2017 se hubiera invertido en
prevenir el embarazo adolescente el país
se hubiese ahorrado 59 millones de
dólares es el resultado de la
investigación de las consecuencias por
la falta de prevención del embarazo de
adolescentes
reflejada por el fondo de población de
la infancia de las naciones unidas- en
países de la región las víctimas son
niñas menores de 14 años a consecuencia
de violencia sexual en su entorno
familiar o escolar según el informe de
la onu advierte que es más rentable
prevenir en argentina colombia guatemala
méxico paraguay y en ecuador
paralelamente el 17 de septiembre de
2019 asamblea nacional voto en contra de
legalizar el aborto desde esa fecha
hasta septiembre 2020 2700 niñas entre 7
y 14 años fueron madres productos de una
violación sexual el estado ecuatoriano
alcanza las metas de salud materna la
prevención de la mortalidad y el
embarazo adolescente según la onu
[Música]
el fondo para la población de naciones
unidas se dio a conocer recientemente un
dato que señala que el embarazo
adolescente le cuesta al paraguay el 0
35 por ciento de su producto interno
bruto esto representa aproximadamente
126 millones de dólares y para tener una
idea de la magnitud de lo que representa
ese dinero podemos decir que con eso se
pueden construir 14 hospitales
especializados en ginecología y
obstetricia el embarazo adolescente es
una epidemia en paraguay que se viene
denunciando desde hace varios años el
organismo internacional estima que en
este país 200.000 embarazos de niñas y
adolescentes se producen cada año estas
tienen entre 14 y 19 años por lo general
y según las denuncias de este organismo
internacional y también de
organizaciones de la sociedad civil esto
se debe en gran medida a la
normalización del abuso sexual
[Música]